Bertrand des KERS c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien de se détendre un peu en ce
moment c'est notre petit soleil Bertrand
des KERS malgré ses problèmes
capillaire non c'est vrai c'est
important révélation à venir embrouille
série sur le roi Charles c'est le
fichoir je dis bien le fichoir dans la
famille royale il y a un livre une série
des grosses révélations ça part en
cacahuète ça part en bénut sans
y
dans un mois le roi Charles I fêtera ses
ans mais cet anniversaire inquiète
aujourd'hui la famille royale car de
nombreux événements pourrai bien mettre
à mal le royaume qui serait déjà
fragilisé par la relation entre Harry et
Méan problème problème au sein du couple
aurait-il de l'eau dans le gaz alors
qu'une réédition de l'autobiographie
explosive d'Arry s'apprête à sortir la
6e saison de la série the crown
débarquera 2 jours après l'anniversaire
du
roi révélation à venir embrouille S sur
le roi Charles rien ne va plus dans la
famille
royale l'
KERS quel
succès tu as fait une nouvelle coiffure
ouais bah fruisser l'automne et les
feuilles
tombent ah ouais c'est pas vrai c'est
pas mal alors qu'est-ce queas comment tu
as pris cette décision de couper oui bah
je me suis dit il faut
couper mais qui t'a donné ce
conseilah est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un de ton entourage j'avais
envie voilà envie de changer alors tu es
content c'est pas mal bon ça va ça te va
bien je te sens pas comme un ouf ah oui
non c'est un peu court pour moi mais
tout le monde me dit que c'est très bien
c'est très bien en fait tu sais quoi
parce que toi tu as pas l'habitude de te
voir comme ça voilà mais je dire que
c'est pas mal allez merci Bertrand
d'avoir été avec
nous allez merci merci d'avoir été là
Bertrand dis-moi c'est pas
l'anniversaire de Charles fre alors
c'est dans c'est dans un mois le 14
novembre très exactement tuenir dans
refinir oui si vous voulez et
l'anniversaire s'annonce d'ors et déjà
assez mal pour parce que il y a pauvre
Charles I vous savez Charles I il a
attendu 70 ans pour devenir roi av de
accès d' Tron en 52 il est roi là il va
faire 75 un chiffre rond donc on
espérait un peu si en tout cas pas de
grande festivité parce que l'Angleterre
vous savez elle est en pleine crise
économique c'est encore bien plus grave
que la France en tout cas on espérait
pouvoir se réjouir au côté de lui parce
que travaille il BSE quand même Charlot
on estime qu'en une année il a rempli
plus de 200 obligations officielles ce
qui éisabeth I a plus ou moins fait ses
5 dernières années de r donc tous les
jours il a un truc lui tous les oui tous
les voir même parfois de deux événems et
ça s'annonce mal pourquoi parce que vous
vous souvenez du fameux livre du prince
Harry verre le suppléant qui s'est vendu
déjà à près de 4 millions d'exemplaires
et ben le 9 novembre prochain il arrive
en version de poche
poetche en petit format en petit form
mais c'est le même en fait pourquoi
alors qu'est-ce que ça a fait ça le
livre jusqu' maintenant était très cher
400 pages vendu 25 € là il est à 10 € ce
veon sait très bien qu'il y a beaucoup
d'anglais qui ont attendu pour pouvoir
enfin livre ils sont
passésêtre pe mais alors surtout surtout
Cyril on va monter
CREN là mais tu as perdu des cheveux
pour ces conneries
franchement arrive donc il fête son
anniversaire le 14 et le 16 fa quoi il
fait quoi il y a qui la lors de
l'anniversaire pas grandchose la meuf
peut-être a du C il y aura du C
il y a David Beckam il y a David Beckam
non non non petit anniversaire
non à Grove il sera dans la campagne
dans le
glowtershire
150 kilomè de Londres Cyril c'est son sa
maison favorite uno c'est un manoir de
campagne qu' adore qu'il a acheté en
1980 sur les conseils de sa sort et
c'est assez petit et il y aura très
exact c'est quoi assez petit pour lui
bah c'est pas grand faut quand même
[Applaudissements]
que la salle à manger peut très
précisément asseoir 16 convit 16
personnes il n aura donc pas un invité
de plus il pas besoin d'il celui-là
galère il galère un peu il est pas dans
la h il est radin disons que la fortune
qu'elle a été il est dans la ou il est
dans la h non je dir pas qu'il est dans
la
nexag c'est quoi la fortune de Charles 3
ah bah c'est estimé la fortune privée à
plus ou moins 2 milliards mais mais
c'est difficile oui mais c'est alors
j'aime pas de donner montants
par c'est privé là il fa il faut
différencier ce qui est privé de ce qui
est public en tout cas ce que l'on peut
dire en effet c'est 7 palais 10 châteaux
52 maisons pouroou pas une agence
immobilière écoutez c'est ce qu'il est
justement c'est ce qu'on pense c'est qu'
est un peu en train de se faire parce
que vous savez Buckingham Palace est en
totale rénovation total travau et on
pense bien qu' va être le premier sou à
ne plus du tout habiter le palais et à
l'ouvrir en permanence au public le K
GAM deviendrait donc un énorme musée non
pour prendre de l'oseille pourquoi parce
que pour l'instantou une est ouvert que
en juillet et août et il rapporte déjà
500000 visiteurs en 2 mois donc imaginez
s'il était ouvert toute l'année en effet
ça pourrait être une machine à ch mais
ce que je voulais dire par rapport à
l'anniversaire l'aurore qui arrive c'est
le 16 novembre 2 jours après son
anniversaire d'
quo the crown c'est quoi la Sée se je
connais je connais pas tu connais pas et
ben on est déjà à la 6e saison c'est la
série la plus regardée sur Netflix Crown
la couronne couronne ah ouais et alors
et bien les quatre premiers épisodes
vont faire la part belle à Diana et on
va la voir beaucoup on nous dit qu'on va
l'avoir énormément le 4è épisode c'est
le pontalma la merces ah ouais
accidentprès Diana revient sous forme de
fantôme non non faut pas partir un peu
en
cacahette fout pas un peu de notre
gueule là ben non je trve la couronne la
couronne oui mais peut-être qu'il se
foutent un peu de notre gueule comme tu
dis mais the Cr c'est quand même
génialement tourné quand on voit les
images quand on voit J il est génial le
réalisateur bref ils ils sont hteux sont
hte là de faire venir Diana on la voil
le derni il est en bonne santé char
j'espère il est en bonne santé char en
bonne santé bien il est gentil ça va il
est
gentilé il a pas des aigreurs destomac
il a surtout des gros
doigts do alors il a des gros dos alors-
qu' alors il a des gros doigs problème
de
circulation mais tout ça pour
dire tout ça pour dire quand Mme que
vous imaginez unee petite parenthèse le
traumatisme que ça a été pour Charles
l'affaire Diana il n' est même pas
encore totalement remis et à de jours de
son annivers
il était déjà il était déjà
avec pendant encore là on lui a reproché
un d'Athie à l'époque c'est pas du tout
ce que je suis en train de dire je dis
oui oui en effet vous
avez est-ce qu'on est encore obligé de
revenir là-dessus justement à 2 jours de
ces 75 ans sous forme de fantôme a lui
parler et lui reprocher des choses je ne
suis pas d'accord c'est la fiction
salut il était déjà avec
parce il a fait combien de temps avec
cam avec il connait cama depuis bien
bien
avant il
tour j'ai l'impression quo il est comme
un ouf sur c'est se c'estisabeth 2 qui
lui a dit tu n'épousera pas Camillia
elle n'est pas suffisamment issue d'un
Milie il a connuelle vient d'où cette
camia cam
Chand c'est son nom de famille mais quoi
et alors qu'est-ce que ça te
faite c'est la non elle est issue d'un
milieu d'un milieu bourgeo il quoi
parents ils font quoi ses parents bah il
ils sont morts maintenant parce que elle
a
ans le Père atts tu as raison là j'ai
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas bien appréendé le
le truc quoi mais il faisait quoi ce par
il était dans le négoce du va le papa
non jure oui je jure je jure I et cé
c'était un bon milieu Cyril mais c'était
pas le milieu aristocratique est-ce que
vous vous imaginez que Diana elle
descend des spencers son père c'est pas
Poké
Poé c'est le genour de l'UM non il
rigole un peu comme ça il veut collerie
mais il ose pas non non mais et et
Camillia alors elle a des frères et
sœurs C Camillia elle tu tu me poses des
questions toi oui oui Camila absolument
elle a elle a deux je de frères et de
mon sur ton Tony son frère Tony par
cœur non non non elle a surtout deux
enfants un fils et une fille ah ouais tu
s'appelle comment Tom Parker balls
etitation la de B les deux BS
qu non mais et donc alors pourquoi tu es
venuadore moi j'adore te faire venir de
la série The clown cy et alors on
continue avec un mois de novembre
absolument désastreux pour les Winsor à
la fin du mois le 29 on a le copain omit
Scoby je sais pas si ça vous quelque
chose ob qui nous ressort un livre finit
de jouer qui l'titule finit de joueroby
c'est le meilleur copry et Méane c'est
leur portepole et omitoby sort un livre
qui est déjà titré à des millions tiré à
des millions d'exemplaires pour fin
novembre et on pense bien cyil qu'il va
balancer davantage encore que ce que
Harry a pu faire on pense que ce que
Harry n'a pas osé dire omit Scoby va lui
oser attaquer à nouveau encore la
famille royale mais pourquoi
c'est le pote de Harry et Méane tu sais
bagarre entre Harry et Méane le clan ce
sexe Harry et Méane et le reste de la
famille royale et donc c'est le pote d'
Harry Méan celui-là il veut faire des
embrouilles aux aut voilà il décrire un
Liv pour ils ve toujours faire des
embrouilles Harry Méan ils se sont pas
calmés non bah apparemment ils se sont
pas calmé du tout alors il paraît que ça
va mal dans l'autre couple ah ou ça
c'est Haran chez William
et il paraî qu'il y a des révélations
sur William dans ce ouais il paraam
ilurait pas Ken
William non mais ah frère attention non
mais on n pas de prof vraiment il a très
pas tu crois que tu V voir son zizi dans
le dans la zigounette éé mettre son
petit zizi dans ça je ne sais pas je
n'ai pas vraiment cette info mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu un moment donné je
sais pas sil a mis son petit zizi tu as
dit toujours kiffé déjà je ne sais pas
s'il a un petit
ziziimporte quoi c'est le meilleur il a
été en tout cas très très proche de rose
hsburry la mar on peut la trouver cette
rose hburry je VZ me la mettre je vais
vous dire tout de suite si la Ken ou pas
tu vas voir ma frère je connais mais je
connais anoun oh le pif vous croyez
quoi rose rose einburry elle a 30 ans et
elle est mariée au marquis d'burry qui
en a
70 s'ennu un peu rose c'estra quoi elle
est marié au marquis de qui au marquis
en marquis Chamel son le vom c'est
ch il est ch Chamel il est chum de ouf
je comprends rien et elle elle est
mariée avec le marquis elle est marié
ave je pense que c'est le 7è marquis on
peut avir une photo on peut avoir une
photo de
c'est rose son pr j'en une si tu veux
non mais non on va la voir non je veux
que les téléspectateurs la VO aussi rose
rose
rose rose et comment tu sais qu'il y a
eu un bail pourquoi parce que kê était
en Sade de Louis donc sa troisème
grossesse et euh ils vont ils ont une
propriété dans la campagne anglaise
Hammer allall très exactement et la
propriété de Hammer allall est à
quelques kilomètres seulement du grand
château familial non ça c'est Kate
sublime mariage en Jordanie Man ou Kate
moi Kate j'adore Kate j'adore Kate et je
sais que Kate elle t'aime bien elle te
kiffe je te dis la
vérité je peux rien dire toutes tes Chan
avec K elle aime les gagnantsê ah oui
elle aime les hommes
puissants la
puissance je pense que je pourrais être
Saam ah vousz bien emble regard phot ça
matche mais c'est pas du tout
Rosens on a demandé rosensburry n que
des photos de William que on l' appelit
la glycine tant elle a cette propension
à monter monter
mon moi aussi m'ppelle la glycine je
monte je mon vous serzpr redescends très
vite vous seriez parfait pour être quoi
et donc ouais donc il a peut-être tu un
donc en effet grand chapitre entier qui
va balancer sur le prince William et un
peu plus on croit que ce que Harry a
voulu nous dire Harry nous a dit que
William n'avait pas un caractère facile
Harry nous a dit que William avait été
jusqu'à le frapper là apparemment Scob
irait jusqu'à nous dire qu'en effet il y
aurait de gros tension parfois entre
William et K et que parfois on va voir
ce qu'il dit dans le Liv mais que
parfois k elle devrait tout faire pourah
pour faire redescendre William si je
peux dire tellement tellement il
s'énerveo vous trou tout le monde l'
trouvé je m'en fous par sms je veux
trouver je veux la voir cette rose ils
vont trouver rosensbur le livre
s'appelle quand même fini de jouer
dernier qu stop the game oui dernier
scandaleame comment il s'appelle le
livre en anglaisame end game end game
end game oui pour qualifier par le jeu
est fini fin jou d'accord et il y a quoi
d'autre il y a quoi d'autre bah c'est
déjà quand même pas mal ah j'ai vu rose
j'ai vu rose ah alors je vous le dis je
préfère je préfère k oui mais k elle est
ultra apprêtée k elle ne sort qu'en
Alexander
McQueen voilà c'est la perfection c'est
la perfection toi tu kiffes Kate j'adore
Kate ah ouais comment ils sont rencontré
déjà Kate et William à l'université de
sa Andrew tu sais comment elle fait à
nouveau'est tu sais comment elle fait qu
pour rencontrer William il y a un
défilet de mode qui est organisé elle
veut absolument apper laattention de
William elle se propose de défiler en
mini robe sauf qu'au dernier moment elle
décide de ne pas du tout défiler en mini
robe elle laisse tomber la robe et elle
défile uniquement avec la nuisette était
sous la robe immédiatement en effet ou
c'est pas la photo
ils ont trouvé une photo mon VI pas
pour con il VI trouver ils ont trouvé
une photo en racera ta Moute là on
dirait regarde ils ont donné son Bul
allez en racera c'est elle
oui voilà voilà voilà une vraie belle on
la voit pas on la voit pas c'est pas ouf
j'ai la photo c'est pas ouf c'est pas
ouf non non je préfère Kate et donc Kate
elle s'est mise en nuisette elle s'est
mise en nuisette parle d' temps là alors
oui absolument on était T et donc quoi
lui il avait en nuisette il a dit bol
ou comment il a dit comment borcola
borcola il a dit borcola oui absolument
et 3 jours après ils étai ensemble dans
un petit cotel un petit pavillon elle
lui a et depuis elle est devenue la
seule ah
voilà
ça c'est pas mon délire c'est pas mon
délire voilà c'est pas mon délire elle
est mign ouis mais arrêtez mais vous
arrêtez arrêtez non
nonign elle est
mign c Kate bientôt libre libre qute
jamais jamais lâchera jamais c'est elle
qui ne lâchera jamais est
parce qu'elle peut pas prendre un billet
celle si elle divorce maintenant est
magnifique qu classe c'est pas une
question d'argent cy les Middleton ont
beaucoup d'argent ils ont bien réussi
financi Midon il fait quoi son père
celui-là C ah ben tu te souviens on en a
parlé le fameux cousa
Péor quoi son père il a inventé le
coussin pter mais oui ils mais oui quoi
tu es en train de me dire que le son
père c'est celui qui a inventé le
coussin pé je t'assure que ça pète
puisque arrête arrête et donc son père
il est milliardaire il a vendu le Coutin
pteur c'est un génie son père il a créé
une société de farce et attrape non mais
arrête mais je te jure c'est son père
donc ça veut dire tu le vois sur un de
50 m tu dis c'est le gars qui a Moné le
coussin pteur c'est quoi cette histoire
on dit surtout maintenant c'est le père
de la future rêve non mais s que c'est
vrai quand ils arrivrive à
buingam il encore le père de Kate il est
au
loin salut
Charles son au moment de toutes les
naissances royales et des jubilé ils
ontch
mais sans décon quoi son père il a fait
fortune dans les farces à attrape quoi
il a le le briquet zizi non mais c'est
tu c'est comme un briquet il y a un zizi
qui sort tu CIS qu' tu c tu peux lui
demander deux briquets Ziz de faux cacas
de briquets Ziz et trois coups péteur
non mais non mais je te jure non mais
c'est ouf sans rigoler attends c'est
incroyable mais non parce que je trouve
aussi que c'est une une une modernité ça
veut donc dire que désormé la monarchie
à l'URE je te disais char n'a pas pu
épouser la femme de sa vie parce qu'elle
n'était pas issue d'un Milie bien
sûr sûr c'est fou toi franchement tu es
un roule de première catégorie tu un
roule tu as d'autre chose à dire je
pense que c'est plus ou moins fini c'est
termin merci merci
on
exceptionnel les gars c'est le meilleur
c'est le meilleur et toi sais toi tu es
vraiment je te jure toi pourquoi j'ai
envie de t'apper Lind Lind parce que tu
es quelques grammes de finesse dans ce
monde de
bruit non c'est vrai ou pas du bien
c'est vrai tu as l'air toujours content
toujours parce que je suis content quand
je viens te voir je viens parler de
choses que j'aime je entendre c'est vrai
hein c'est he croqué tu es accroqué
c'est vrai que tuas accroqué croque-moi
oh c'est ton style c'est ton style ton
style Bertrand non mais en toute amitié
comment c'est en toute amitié en toute
amitié c'est mon style d'ami qui est ton
style ici ton style bah j'ai déjà dit
plein de fois que Jean-Michel et
Delphine c'est mon style mais tu sais il
y a un zizi et pas zizi là si je dois
choisir choisis un trio toi jeanmie et
Delphine pas chois juste laisser juste
un duo t'emmerdes pas non mais
t'emmerdes pas et non mais c'est tu le
trouves beau Hugo est très beau oui Hugo
est très beau oh là je va pas encore
couper mes cheveux et
puis cette nelle mieux tuas upgrad ta
glow ouis c'est GL mod je te jure par y
en a plein qui ont GD cette année ah oui
qui qui il y en a qui ont GD je dirai
pas nom il y en a qui on
GD ouais je te le dis moi j'ai GD depuis
août toi tu non depuis aoû j'ai GD je sa
j'ai glowown pour ceux qui voilà je vous
dis mais là il faut que je que je
reparte merci en tout cas et tu veux tu
veux tuas plus rien à me dire je pense
pas je pour l'anniversaire ah non mais
j'ai écrit j'ai écrit au palais pour
demander le le gâteau qui va être servi
au roi et si on arrive à obtenir il faut
pas faire un bouscoutou non pas un
bouscoutou non non non non je pense que
ça va être quelque chose de très léger
d'Iria je sens bien quelque chose au
fruits un CAAC un cac oui genre un peu
bavarois un peu fr un croquant un
croquant avec dans la limonade comme ça
tu le trempes et puis si on arrive à
avoir la recette et ben je vousadresse
le gâteau non tu veux pas il y a pas un
croquant non non non quoi non c'est vrai
du dro du Dr les G les gel LG arissa
arissa tu connais le gâteau l'arissa non
non non très bon ah ou dis dis qui fasse
avec du
zabillon sur ma vie c'est un grand ki
frère voilà ok je t'embrasse en tout cas
ça m'a fait très plaisir de te voire je
t'embrasse les chîn